In diesem Ökosystem hat
dieser unglaubliche Gedanke Platz,
es könnte ein Vorteil sein,
wenn ich meine Kinder umbringe.
Frank Urbaniok ist der einflussreichste
und wohl auch bekannteste
Gerichtspsychiater der Schweiz.
Wenn die Medien Fragen haben, liefert er Antworten.
Wir sprechen mit ihm über die
eindrücklichsten Fälle mit denen er als
Gutachter zu tun hatte.
In der Nacht vom 23. auf den 24. Dezember 2007
wurde die Polizei zu einer Familienwohnung in Horgen/ZH gerufen.
Dort stellten sie fest, dass
die beiden Kinder,
Zwillinge, siebenjährig,
mit dem Kissen erstickt waren,
die Kinder waren tot.
In der Wohnung waren die Mutter
und der Vater anwesend.
Es gab ein paar Hinweise auf eine Unordnung,
es hätte auch ein Einbruch sein können.
Man stellt aber schnell fest, dass niemand von aussen eingedrungen war.
Somit war klar:
Es gab zwei Tote und zwei Lebende,
und die Täterschaft ist somit bei den zwei
Lebenden zu suchen.
Ein Tatort, zwei Verdächtige, kein Geständnis.
Das ist die Situation, als Frank Urbaniok
in diesem Fall zugezogen wird.
Ich habe das Gutachten sowohl über die Mutter,
als auch über den Vater gemacht.
Zum Zeitpunkt des Gutachtens
musste man annehmen,
dass einer von beiden Täter oder Täterin ist,
und ein anderer ist unschuldig.
Das ist eine sehr spezielle Situation gewesen.
Als die Mutter zum Prozess gefahren wird,
liegt noch immer kein Geständnis vor.
Im Gegenteil, sie beteuert ihre Unschuld.
Urbaniok tritt vor Gericht als Gutachter auf
und soll Antworten
auf die vielen, offenen Fragen liefern.
Der Gutachter darf keine Aussagen
zum Sachverhalt machen,
im Sinne von, der ist schuldig, der ist unschuldig.
Das steht allein dem Gericht zu.
Man nennt das eine gerichtliche Sachverhaltswürdigung.
Das ist richtigerweise verbotenes Gebiet
für den Psychiater.
Aber hier kommt das Gutachten
dieser Grenze schon sehr nah.
Denn ich habe sowohl die Mutter,
als auch den Vater begutachtet.
Meine Schlussfolgerungen waren so,
dass ich für die Mutter einen plausiblen
Delikt-Mechanismus darlegen kann.
Das bedeutet, ich habe Persönlichkeits-
eigenschaften gefunden,
mit denen ich das Delikt
theoretisch erklären konnte.
Beim Vater habe ich
solche Eigenschaften auch gesucht,
aber ich habe keine gefunden.
Das heisst, die Situation war so,
dass ich für die Mutter
einen Delikt-Mechanismus darlegen konnte.
Für den Vater konnte ich das nicht.
So weit kann ein Gutachter vor Gericht gehen,
aber auf keinen Fall weiter.
Das war damals ein Geschworenen-
Gerichtsprozess,
eine der allerletzen Gerichtsprozesse
mit Geschworenen.
Ich erinnere mich gut daran,
dass einer der Geschworenen mich fragte:
«Herr Urbaniok, Sie haben jetzt die Täterin erklärt –
trauen Sie es ihr auch zu?»
Ich habe schon gesehen, wie der Gerichtspräsident zusammenzuckt.
Wenn ich in dem Moment auch nur ein Zeichen
gegeben hätte,
dann hätte ich die Grenze ganz klar
überschritten.
Dann wäre ich mit Befangenheit
aus dem Spiel gewesen.
Das ist die Grenze,
die ich nicht überschreiten darf.
Ich muss sagen, dass ich aus
meinem Fachgebiet plausible Szenarien darlegen kann.
Im einen Fall kann ich Verbindungen
zwischen Persönlichkeitseigenschaften
und dem Tatverhalten darlegen
und im anderen Fall nicht.
Dann ist stopp.
Da ist die rote Linie, jetzt ist das Gericht am Zug.
Das Gericht und die Geschworenen
hören an diesem Tag auch,
wie die Angeschuldigte versuchte,
den Gutachter bewusst in die Irre zu führen.
Es wurden sehr viele Möglichkeiten ausgeschlossen,
bis man am Schluss herausarbeiten konnte,
was das individuelle Profil der Täterin war.
Kurz bevor diese Arbeit abgeschlossen war,
sagte sie beiläufig, dass sie
Schlafwandlerin sei.
Damit hat sie nahe gelegt,
ob es nich sein könnte,
dass sie die Tat beim Schlafwandeln begangen hat
und sich gar nicht mehr daran erinnern kann.
Das ist heikel,
weil es gibt Fälle, in denen
Täter für schuldunfähig erklärt wurden,
weil man gesagt hat, die haben die Tat beim Schlafwandeln begangen
und können sich gar nicht daran erinnern.
Es könnte im Zweifelsfall noch so sein,
dass man es gar nicht ausschliessen kann.
Das hat eine grosse Problematik in den Fall hineingebracht.
Ich habe mir überlegt,
wie wir damit umgehen können.
Sie hat mir gegenüber geäussert,
dass es eine bestimmte Tablette gibt,
immer wenn sie diese Tablette nimmt,
tritt das Schlafwandeln auf.
Ich habe nachgefragt,
ob das immer der Fall ist.
Sie hat gesagt, dass es immer der Fall sei.
An dem Abend der Tat habe sie
diese Tablette auch genommen.
Dann haben wir die Täterin in das
Schlaflabor gebracht.
Wir zeichnen die Hirnaktivitäten
während des Schlafs auf.
Zuerst einmal ohne Tablette,
da hat sich überhaupt nichts
Auffälliges gefunden.
Ich habe ihr gesagt,
dass nichts auffällig ist,
wir das gleiche aber
noch einmal mit der Tablette machen.
In dieser Nacht sieht man, wie
die Täterin aufsteht,
roboterhaft ein paar Schritte macht
und sich wieder ins Bett legt.
Es sieht aus wie Schlafwandeln,
aber anhand der Hirnströme sah man,
dass es kein Schlafwandeln war,
das war im Wachzustand,
das war vorgetäuscht.
Später gesteht die Frau die Tat,
und gibt zu,
schon ihr erstes Kind getötet,
und einen plötzlichen Kindstod
vorgetäuscht zu haben.
Ein zentraler Problembereich
in diesem Fall
war der «instabile Realitätsbezug».
Das bedeutet, dass man sich
der Realität wenig verpflichtet fühlt.
Subjektiv können sie das sagen
und glauben,
was sich subjektiv gut anfühlt.
Unabhängig davon, ob es stimmt,
plausibel ist oder mit irgendeiner
Wahrnehmung übereinstimmt
oder nicht.
Im Extremfall kann ein Mensch
mit instabilem Realitätsbezug
auf einer Wiese einen Hasen sehen
und dann sagen,
weil sich das für ihn gut anfühlt,
dass er rosa sei.
Wenn ich jetzt sage, dass der Hase grau sei,
würde der Mensch mit voller Überzeugung
antworten,
dass er doch rosa sei.
Das geht deswegen, weil bei diesen Menschen
die Kopplung zwischen Wahrnehmung, Gedanken und Emotionen frei kombinierbar ist.
Sie setzen das so zusammen, wie es sich gut anfühlt.
So können sie absurde Dinge
stimmig für sich denken
und als richtig erachten.
In diesem Ökosystem hat
dieser unglaubliche Gedanke Platz,
es könnte ein Vorteil sein,
wenn ich meine Kinder umbringe.
Wieso mussten die Zwillinge an
Weihnachten 2007 sterben?
Auch diese Frage beantwortet der Gutachter dem Gericht.
Das Motiv ist,
dass die Täterin die Komplexität
ihres Lebens reduziert hat.
Sie hat in gewisser Weise,
man möchte es kaum ausprechen,
aber sie sich hat gedacht,
das Leben wäre einfacher
ohne die Kinder.
Später hat sie dann gesagt,
dass sie die Kinder
grundsätzlich abgelehnt habe,
und sie einen gewissen
Hass oder Neid auf sie verspürt hat.
Letztlich war es so,
dass sie sich ein Leben
mit oder ohne Kinder vorgestellt hat.
Subjektiv war für sie die Welt ohne Kinder attraktiver.
Da spielt der instabile Realitätsbezug
eine grosse Rolle.
Es gibt auch andere Eltern, die sich mal fragen,
wie das Leben ohne die Kinder wäre?
Hätte dies nicht Vorteile?
Aber man würde sofort einen solchen
Gedanken verwerfen,
und sich sagen,
dass man das gar nicht weiterdenken darf.
Es fallen einem sofort
tausend Gegenargumente ein,
dagegen gewalttätig zu werden.
Das ist eben
der instabile Realitätsbezug.
In diesem Umfeld
gibt es die Bremse nicht,
gibt es keine Realitätskontrolle.
Man denkt nicht noch einmal darüber nach,
sondern es passt in einen Moment,
es passt in eine Stimmung
und ein Gefühl.
Es wird dann ganz zwanglos eingearbeitet
und kann dann zur Realität werden.
Was sich bei anderen Menschen nie
so weit entwickeln könnte.
Die Täterin wird zu einer lebenslänglichen
Freiheitsstrafe verurteilt,
verbunden mit einer ambulanten Therapie.